now daniel radcliffe presumably you are
familiar with Miriam's potty-mouthed
because are you because you ran high
water but did you actually work together
yeah yeah but I don't know I've been
told there was a swear jar involved on
set but I can't remember that I don't
you remember you swearing a lot of money
I was probably careful when it was you
but when you know with the other kids I
didn't fall
I was just talking backstage if that's
what you call that funny little
apparently it's 20 years since Harry
Potter came out there since we started
filming the first one and your balls
have dropped since
[Applause]
they're just weak kids thing we get it
yes
[Applause]
yeah but but it's interesting because
Professor sprouts which you know you're
in the second film and the last oh yeah
I should have been in all of them yes
that was a grave oversight on I'm
holding you responsible
anyway it was wonderful to be in the two
that I was in and I'm very proud of it
but you do get recognized as professor
sprout I do
I mean I think I've changed since then
but people do recognise me and funnily
enough in Lithuania
[Applause]
have you come just to see professor
sprout the film is called professors for
after the jury
but I was mobbed in Lithuania maybe
because I was Jewish I don't know the
only one cheering now
that's incredible IQ being marbled
Alania and you a professor sprout
imagine being this I know what what was
it like I mean it's weird and funny and
I think I the best way to see it always
was like weird and funny because it will
it you know and it abscent flows and
sometimes it's in your life a lot and
sometimes it's not in terms of gang
recognizing there's been lots of very
odd moments I was chased out of a
science museum in Spain because
everything was in Spanish there and I
couldn't understand anything inside so
it was time to leave anyway but someone
thought you were something else in New
York recently oh yeah you know what
didn't this did not come up in in with
it yeah so so me my girlfriend fostered
a dog and it we sort of got our friends
to adopt it this is not necessary for
the story there's a dog with me i I was
on the street with this dog and my
girlfriend was in the shop and so I was
said it was very cold
I've got my hoodie in my fleece my
fleece hoodie and and then a big coat
over that and the dog was really cold so
I'll just kneel by you and let's Stroke
Ewing did I try and keep you warm and
then and then I saw this guy look up on
me like ten yards away and smile and I
was like yeah and just carried on then
he walked past me and he came back like
you're about five steps past me then
just reappeared for the five dollar bill
over my shoulder and then gaze other
coffee-mate
like oh my god I was I don't think I'm
Brett I'm wearing nice clothes I thought
yes I was very much that was a wake-up
call I'm Harley I have to maybe you know
I do maintain cuz the person that owns
the dog has also been mistaken for a
homeless person with this dog I think
the dog looks very cold and sweet and
vulnerable
[Music]
you